crowds gathering in sent Peter's Square
to see Pope Francis this weekend just a
few hours after addressing the faithful
the pontiff for the first time met with
people who have been sexually abused by
catholic clergy the Vatican released no
pictures of the meeting in order it says
to protect the privacy of the six
victims
vatican spokesman federico lombardi says
the six attended morning mass and then
met with the pope separately for about
30 minutes at his private residence
dundee sean the pope says he hopes with
this gesture to express his closeness
with the tens of thousands of people
around the world whose lives have been
ruined by abuse at the hands of catholic
priests but victims groups a pope
francis has waited too long to address
the issue and they say the vatican must
take more action they want the pope to
send a very strong signal to catholic
officials around the world but
particularly in the developing world
that whenever there's even the slightest
suspicion that someone a priest has
abused a child that that suspicion
should be brought to civil authorities
earlier this year the pope condemn
sexual abuse in no uncertain terms
comparing it to a satanic mass he set up
a commission to investigate allegations
but critics say it is not transparent
and without more radical change the true
extent of abuse will never be known